O'Shea Jackson jr. actor musician son of
Ice Cube calling Shay
good to have you hey good to be here I'm
with it do you want to jump into this
yeah you know I completely agree with
that whole wait Marshawn should have got
the ball and now yeah you know you see a
hall-of-famer over Tiki Barber how many
Raines Tiki Barber he doesn't have any
that's crazy well he retired season
before they won the Super ya I believe
he was going hard on the Giants you know
a little bit talking about yeah run
office everything and then you know what
can you do
yeah I like I like beast mode uh you
know bees mow has always been a been a
dope dude but are you a Raider fan like
your dad oh god no no no no way it's uh
you know it was it was a point in my
life where I was watching my father beat
his head into it and you know and then I
just believed in the whole Ganon curse I
call it the Ganon Richardson one once he
went down like the Raiders just were
never ever the same you know and it's
it's it's sad are you a ram fan
oh yeah man los Angelino I asked my mom
like we're not from Oakland I'm not from
Vegas like I don't I want to I want to
have a team and when it was Rams charges
or Raiders I said whoever came first I
got a ride with Hart and rams came first
and it's been a great choice in my house
did it hurt that Super Bowl loss of
course it did cuz it's to Boston it's
not that we lost the Super Bowl because
that's already gonna just be monumental
but it just had to be LA verse Boston
and we lost oh this is the whole Lakers
Celtic thing yeah oh by the way I'm
happy that the Celtics lost it makes me
feel good every time y'all are you won't
so you what's going on with the Lakers
in your opinion man the Lakers gonna be
alright right now is it's it's turmoil
we've always been the best soap opera in
the lead but the magic thing is the only
thing that shocked me you know I didn't
expect to win the championship this year
I chalked it up to Golden State like
everybody else so LeBron take your time
film what you got a film but next year I
need to be in a position to show that
we're moving forward yeah but who's
gonna come there and play man we don't
Lakers everybody
acting like they haven't been coming
there we got LeBron James last year
people told me I wasn't gonna do that we
know what fun went there for business
not this is about business well it's
business people like business bring come
on down and play some bass who's gonna
go the business who's gonna go somebody
with a K in their name either Kawhi
Kevin Kyrie I don't know maybe it's one
of the Kardashian we got enough of those
we need I would definitely love Kyrie
and LeBron a team back up I don't know
you know what Dan if I get anybody
that's the one thing Lakers we remember
we remember these times all you
single-digit championship sign you know
throw your parades because when we back
we remember everything we weren't gone
soon all right let me tell people what
you've been doing here so you were in
straight out of Compton I was you played
your dad was there any chance that you
weren't getting that role that your dad
might have said maybe we need somebody
else oh no for sure it definitely was
did you audition I auditioned for two
years to be your to be your dad yeah for
two years straight of you know the
studio and you know the director Gary
Graham when they hear my dad say they
want you know me to play him it's like
whoo you know cute we got a we got we
got a bunch of established actors
they're already ahead in line and I had
to get a coach and I work with that
coach through that two-year process Erin
speiser and he's giving me the tools
that have helped me in so many roles he
for sure helped me with long shot long
shot we had to do a lot of improv and a
lot of acting on the fly and I would I
would not be able to do that for what
for Erin speiser
okay so you play your dad yeah when do
you know that you've nailed your dad
you know after you do something for two
years you know you get on you finally
get on that set you have confidence in
yourself you know it's not really a lot
that anybody could tell me about my role
I got it down and after the fact after
Straight Outta Compton came out and
people said you know you can act you
know you could you could take his series
if you wanted to that's what I thought
to make a
you're out of it in the beginning it was
just to submit my family's legacy but
afterwards it's about bringing some
checks in wait what were you gonna do if
you weren't gonna if this movie never
came out yeah I was gonna be a
screenwriter
I wanted to write I was going to USC for
screenwriting and I wanted to write
scripts for video games in my mind I
could make you pay $13 be ticket or $60
again so you know grand theft auto made
a billion dollars in a weekend I was
trying to get a piece of that now you're
also looking at you're in a movie with
Aubrey Plaza you're elizabeth Olsen
Gerard Butler 50 cent you Michael B
Jordan Jamie fought like you're in all
these movies now and you're also in long
shot with Charlize Theron and Seth Rogen
that comes out on Friday yeah look at
you
yeah I'm trying I'm sorry you're doing
I'm out here Bianca what happened at
young Kobe I'm just trying to be young
Kobe you know I'm just trying to get my
shine in around these vets I'll be the
supporting actor you know I'll be Han
Solo every button Luke is the hero gives
the hero yeah but is he cooler than Han
Solo so you got to be Han Solo until
they give you an Indiana Jones you went
to the premiere last night yeah anything
happened yeah I destroyed it how'd you
do it was incredible I just every
interview I had was just a massacre you
know yeah and the after-party was it a
great time but I got up early so that's
what's up no it's good because if you're
hanging out with Seth Rogen you know it
could be trouble yeah it was a lot of
thinking going on thank you
explain what this movie is about well my
man Seth Rogen plays Fred flower ski
who's a political journalist down on his
luck and he comes to his best friend
played by me Lance and we we have a
pretty wild night boys to men is
actually there at the party that we go
to so that's a cool little cameo night
and he sees Charlotte feel played by
Charlize Theron who was his former
babysitter now turned Secretary of State
and she's running for the Presidency so
it's a it's love at first sight for him
he wants that in his life and I'm all
for it I'm his best friend hyping
and chaos ensues do you think Seth would
really let's say in real life okay which
Seth have a shot with Charlize Theron
Charlie's been single for ten years
she's ready she's ready to even for Seth
it's about being confident who if you
got to be confident in self and every
woman like to laugh you gotta you gotta
be holding the funny man if ya don't
bring the funny you're born I think I
called out your dad didn't he mess
around and get a triple-double yeah
who's how did this work how'd you get
the assist he did his own stats I said I
said cube nobody does that
he loved and he messed around you don't
mess around and get a triple Doug
focused as Russell Westbrook if he ever
messed around and got those fours triple
doubles yeah and what kind of game did
your dad cuz I I kind of wanted to DM up
a little bit let me tell you my dad is a
he'd be a guard that'll post you up he
knows how to use the body and that
midranges is true okay it's true my
jumper is wet yeah yeah it is wet Google
Earth at Google it me and Patrick
jumpers way yeah water
what what what age were you when you saw
NWA
oh no your dad they were done two years
before you were born
yeah they were oh so I was I was super
biased when's the first time you listen
to NWA my older brother Darryl had to
show me when I was fifteen you know just
show me young pops and everything that
was about that when I was a kid any
other rapper I was just like nah I'm not
listening to you only my dad nobody else
just super biased and then when I found
out using a group I was like well he's
obviously the coolest one in the group
and it's just how it's always been I
ride for him no matter what and what how
old were you when you saw boys from the
hood honestly my grandmother showed me
boys in the hood I think I was I think
maybe around the same age me and my
sister and I you know you got to see my
dad get down a little bit as far as
acting that movie's heavy was the
heaviest one I had seen at that time
from him and you know boys in the hood
recipes John singers lost John sing when
he was 24 at the time
when he did that movie yeah John was
yeah he's first out of the first out of
USC and told my dad you know I wanna I
got this vision for you to be in this
film and then my dad said it's just this
film student like yeah whatever did he
know that that right there that meeting
right there would change his life for
the better but that that's such a
powerful movie and the fact that it got
made and really what it represented it
allowed South Central to have a voice to
show what you know because John was
basing this off people he knew in his
real life yeah and that's what you know
the more you can make art imitating life
the more it's relatable and the longer
it stands in time and it's it's a that's
a great movie yeah but so we straight
out of Compton yeah you know I try I try
to get it down but did your dad when did
your dad say or what did he say when he
saw you on the screen he you know he was
on set every day for Straight Outta
Compton so he he said it's like watching
me win a Super Bowl over and over again
you know it just to see me in a new
element and making it my own and now you
know I got every time he's at a premiere
I got to see the you know the the grunts
of approval you know that was good son
you know I'm waiting for that and he has
the scene long shot yeah but I know
he'll love long shot every film I try to
I try to steal the show
you know he saw Godzilla he loves
Godzilla yeah you're in Godzilla yeah
that's really what I'm Godzilla is the
biggest star I've ever got to work with
for sure hands down because it's
Godzilla because it's gods he's got over
33 movies who else is in with Godzilla
Godzilla's got Kyle Chandler Milly Bobby
Brown the evil genius also we got a Vera
Farmiga oh yeah that's a Ken Watanabe my
man Anthony Ramos and uh Elizabeth
Ludlow that's G team we were just
soldiers
we had rough days on on the set so
that's I went to war with those guys I'd
love it I mean you're this is big-boy
stuff here that I'm trying I'm out here
but if you could have your own sports
radio show Oh would you rather do that
then now you've done that well with the
ESPN affiliate in Los Angeles
yeah I I use my fame to force myself on
a sport and like they just say yes
come on down and so that's cool and I
get to just say things about the Lakers
and be abusive to all the other inferior
teams in the league do you hate the
Clippers with every bit of me why
because I mean look at them I wish okay
who do you hate worse clippers Celtics
Warriors oh I hate the Celtics man you
know if whose clippers recessed Paulie
bring in bring in Larry Bird Larry let's
bring in Larry Bird I just I was almost
gonna say Clippers in the finals I had
to I bit my tongue a little bit but you
know alternate universe where this would
ever happen
I cannot cheer for the Celtics I cannot
do it I you know in oay tie thought Kobe
was gonna be the only Laker to not beat
the Celtics like I don't like them and I
really don't like the Clippers so you
know I hope they never make it to the
finals ever both of them what if you had
to shoot a movie in Boston man I'd have
to hear it every day
Mark Wahlberg's brother Jim attacks me
on Twitter yeah they're very aggressive
a band from Boston and you know he's
that's my dude you know Mark Wahlberg
that's that's my guy I play catch with
him on a set of three kings like my
respect Mark Wahlberg but I just don't
like Boston and they know it and I don't
shy away from him go Lakers now your dad
took you to the movie set with three
kings yeah and he said so that now I
heard there were punches thrown on that
movie [ __ ] you know that true stuff out
in war I heard there was some creative
disagree okay you know I never saw
anything being a child being safe in the
trailer but your dad was your dad
involved in this oh no my dad is too
cool Plus when's the last time your dad
was gonna fight oh man we haven't seen
that guy ever again you know we can't
even remember and he's he's the type
that he's probably dying for a fight
somewhere famous I can't get it all but
I know he's my dad yeah he's a he's a
ruffian that ice cute but but he had
there was a run where like he's being
investigated by the FBI I mean there was
some serious stuff going on with NWA
they they uh they could trial they may
but but you were you were oblivious so
the family you know you I don't know how
that yeah you know my dad has always
been the utmost professionally done put
himself in any type of situation where
himself or any of the families in danger
I know
we know the captain of the ship got us
does she did he allow you to get away
with stuff no did he know everything you
were doing no I'm sure parents know a
lot cool dad but then he might be no
he's a cool dad as long as long as your
room and school is alright he's the
chill his dad but he starts slipping the
nose that's when he you know that's when
you get upset but those are
responsibilities you know you just as
long as you hold to your
responsibilities the chillers do you
commit you could be around as him
are you still rapping no man once I
realized that you know personally you
know just as a son I feel like they're
just roles that they won't give my dad
because he was a rapper you know because
he's ice cube because they can't see him
in that light and I don't like that and
I wanted to avoid that because I feel
like they typecast rappers a lot in
cinema and I didn't want to be a part of
that so my love for music went into
producing my brother Darrow he's gettin
lynch mob off the ground he's got a
bunch of dope new artists so I produced
cuz they can't get mad at me for the
lyrics if I'm just making the beat
around it but who gave you oh em gee is
shootin my dad on the set of Ellen says
it and without discussing nothing with
me just blurted it nothing is more
hardcore than the set of Ellen and he
drops it and I'm just like wow now I
have to make this work you know I
appreciate you know just start me off
rough you know and it's just straight
out of Bed Bath & Beyond Ellen started
me off rough man yeah but you know I
made it work I'll take the whole che
name he's not using it but you're just
going by CheY CheY yeah CheY butter
second best rapper of all time is oh is
second best together
I gotta just say just straight for
longevity I'll take jay-z but my top 5
lists if I came here first of all
ice cubes most dangerous rapper ever
made by and demand of sleep what's just
what's the best lyric that you're
allowed to say oh man the best lyric
that I'm allowed to say and that's not
that's really tough my dad is a really
aggressive okay
brilliance of emcee second you know I'm
not gonna put the next four in order but
Ice Cube's number one
I gotta go jay-z gotta go a little way
gotta go Eminem got to go Andre 3000 and
I'm good a lot of people gonna be upset
at me but boohoo you know do something
about it that's what that's those are
the top five I could listen to them for
the rest of my life I'll be good I like
biggie yeah of course you don't even
know all this New York stuff no no it's
a dance it's not that I just think he
was the man I just man like just I mean
I'm straight out of Ohio I feel okay I
feel you but I just I thought biggie was
something different you hid the way that
I like listening to biggie acapellas
just just hearing how he can tell a
story was just untouchable I just wish
we had more you know more yeah that's
true I'll be in the same with Tupac
you're the same and I'll you know oh my
god I'm not even gonna say meant about
that all right
he is O'Shea Jackson jr. the third yeah
yeah hey Congrats on all this and good
luck and we'd love to have you back
again to talk some sports yeah I was I'm
not filming I'm not doing that no no I
appreciate that good luck with the movie
it's out on Friday right Charlize Theron
mm-hmm I thought it was Charlize Theron
you know I thought it was thrown I've
been saying everybody's name wrong the
whole press tour is Charlize Theron it's
June Rafe al and Ravi Patel and I've
been butchering though is there any
nudity with Seth Rogen in this movie oh
oh no I heard there's one there's a
scene he deuce he do show slight cheek
okay
all right and that's it's uncomfortable
because when you say nudity I'm hoping
for Charlize Theron but you're saying oh
it's broken
Canadian slight cheek all right I love
it
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app